>> OH, BIDEN.
>> Greg: HOW LOW CAN JOE GO?
GLAD I DIDN'T SCREW THAT UP,
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
HYPOCRITICAL.
FIRST OF ALL JOE BEING CALLED ON
FOR HIS ASSOCIATE TO OFFICIAL
STATEMENT ON THE FOREIGN
PRIME MINISTER SHINZO ABE.
WHEN HE BLAME THE ASSASSINATION
ON GUN VIOLENCE.
WAY TO BURY THE LEDE OR THE
LEAD.
JAPAN HAS SOME OF THE STRICTEST
GUN LAWS IN THE WORLD BUT IT'S
THE GUN VIOLENCE AGAIN.
AT LEAST JOE DIDN'T PIN IT ON
WHITE SUPREMACY OR TRUMP.
GIVEN A WEEKEND JOE'S HANDLERS
WILL LINK THE WHOLE
ASSASSINATION TO JANUARY 6TH.
THEN THERE IS MESS.
>> THIS IS A QUOTE NOW FROM THE
MAJORITY.
WOMEN ARE NOT WITHOUT ELECTORAL
OR POLITICAL POWER.
IT'S NOTEWORTHY THE PERCENTAGE
OF WOMEN WHO REGISTERED TO VOTE
AND CAST A BALLOT IS
CONSISTENTLY HIGHER THAN THE
PERCENTAGE OF THE MEN WHO DO SO
END OF QUOTE THE LINE.
WOMEN ARE NOT WITHOUT ELECTORAL
OR POLITICAL POWER.
>> Greg: HE REALLY IS A
HOSTAGE READING A RANSOM NOTE.
BUT HE DOES IT SO WELL, I
BELIEVE HIM.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" GOT THE
GO-AHEAD TO STOP COVERING FOR
THE COGNITIVE CUPCAKE SAYING "HE
OFTEN SHUFFLES WHEN HE WALKS,
AND AGE WHERE HE WILL TRIP ON A
WIRE.
HE STUMBLES OVER WORDS DURING
PUBLIC EVENTS AND THEY HOLD
THEIR BREATH TO SEE IF HE MAKES
IT TO THE END WITHOUT A GAFFE."
YOU'D HOLD YOUR BREATH TO IF JOE
MISSES THE 10:00 A.M. CHANGING.
MEANWHILE, HE SAID WORST THINGS
ABOUT YOU, BELIEVE ME.
THE APPROVAL RATING HAD A
ALL-TIME LOW, 29% IN A NEW
CIVICS POLL AND THE NUMBER
DROPPED TO WEAR.
IF JOE MIGHT TRY TO SNIP HIS
HAIR.
JOE'S WOES GROW, THANK GOD FOR
HUNTER AND HIS NEWEST VIDEO
LEAKED FOOTAGE OF HIM AND WHAT
APPEARS TO BE CRACKED.
>> I JUST MADE OUT THE BAG.
2.06.
>> 2.07.
WE GOT THE BAG.
>> Greg: IT REALLY IS THE
SMARTEST GUY JOE KNOWS.
SHE WAS OFF BY IT .01 OF A GRAM
AND HE USED A SCALE AND NAILED
THE ON IT.
AND I HAVE TO ADMIT IT LOOKS
LIKE PARMESAN CHEESE, HE WAS
RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
WE'VE GOT A LOT TO GO OVER HERE,
AND I DON'T AGREE WITH PEOPLE
HACKING PEOPLE'S PHONES,
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE PERSON WHO
IS HACKED TAKES ME WISH I HAD
MORE FUN LIFE.
>> HE MAKES ME FEEL BORING.
>> Greg: LIKE I DON'T DO
ANYTHING ANYMORE.
HE'S NOT THAT YOUNG EITHER, AND
HE'S GOING DOWN SLIDES NAKED,
MONEY WIRED TO AND FROM FROM
RUSSIAN ESCORTS.
>> MONEY WIRED TO AND FROM
PROBABLY IS A BONUS THAT MOST OF
US DON'T HAVE.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
>> I FEEL LIKE IF THAT WAS ME,
I'D BE IN BIG TROUBLE.
>> Greg: YOU'RE NOT THE
OFFSPRING OF A PRESIDENT.
>> IF THAT WERE ME, I DON'T LIKE
I'D BE COMING BACK TO WORK.
IT'S A BUMMER IF I WAS STILL
ABLE TO COME TO WORK AND BE A
CRACK HEAD, I DON'T THINK I
COULD BALANCE THE TWO.
THAT'S WHY NEVER SMOKED CRACK
BECAUSE I THINK I WOULD LOVE IT.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
YOU GUYS, TOO?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: WE ARE REALLY
CHANGING.
JIM, WHEN WE ARE OLD, WE ARE
GOING TO BE SCREWED UP.
RIGHT?
I'M SCREWED UP NOW.
BUT WE ARE NOT PRESIDENT.
>> NO.
NO, WE ARE NOT.
I WOULD HOPE THE FIRST TIME I
DROP A DEUCE IN MY PANTS AND I'M
DON'T KNOW WHERE I'M AT, THEY
WOULDN'T LET ME READ A PROMPTER
AND RUN A COUNTRY.
THAT'S JUST ME THOUGH.
I JUST KNOW IF YOU ASK ME TO GET
IN A COMPACT CAR WITH HIM WHILE
HE'S DRIVING, I AIN'T DOING THAT
AND THAT ALONE SHOULD TELL YOU
WE HAVE A SERIOUS SITUATION.
>> Greg: HAVING TO REMIND HIM
OF THINGS LIKE BASIC THINGS, A
LITTLE CAR.
BUT THEN I WANT TO ASK YOU,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS JUMPING
OVER IT, THEY ARE DOING IT
BECAUSE THEY GOT THE GO-AHEAD.
THEY'RE GOING TO GET RID OF HIM.
>> THAT'S WHAT ALL OF THIS IS
ABOUT.
MAKING IT SAFE FOR SOMEBODY TO
RUN AGAINST HIM.
IF YOU READ THE ARTICLE, IT'S
AMAZING, ALL THE AIDS AND DOING
THE OTHER STUFF
SHARP AS A TACK, CALLED UP IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT, REDOING
POLICY PAPERS IN THE P SO MY
REASON PEOPLE VOTED FOR HIM WAS
BECAUSE HE'S OLD.
THEY WANTED NO TROUBLE.
OF THE YOUNG GIRL AND INCREDIBLY
HEALTHY MAN ALSO STOPPED PEOPLE
FROM DRILLING FROM OIL, STOPPED
PEOPLE FROM BUILDING REFINERIES,
AND WROTE CHECKS TO PEOPLE TO
INCREASE INFLATION, THEY BEGAN
29% TOO.
THIS GUY HAS A POLICY PROBLEM,
NOT AN AGE PROBLEM.
STUTTERING OLD MEN WOULD BE FINE
IF HE WASN'T SUCH A.
>> Greg: I HAD A GREAT FACT TO
MAKE ABOUT HOW JOE IS AN EMPTY
VESSEL CONTROLLED BY YOUNG
BOOKSTORES.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM
>> THE PROBLEM ISN'T COMING FROM
JOE BIDEN, PEOPLE WITHIN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
I THINK BIDEN'S REALLY TRYING TO
FLOOD THE ZONE.
IF THE GRANDPA GOOF AND
BUFFOONERY IS AN ACT.
AND HE DOESN'T WANT TO DO
ANYTHING.
IF THEY THINK I'M SO OUT OF IT
AND I'M SHUFFLING AROUND HERE
LIKE BEDROOM SHOES I STOLE FROM
A CHEAP MOTEL, CHEAP MOTELS
DON'T HAVE BEDROOM SHOES ANYWAY,
IF THEY REALLY WANTED TO IMPROVE
HIS PHYSICAL PERFORMANCE THEY
CAN BUY HIM SOME NEW SHOES.
YOUR FEET CHANGE WHEN YOU GET
OLD.
YOU GET FALLEN ARCHES, BUT THEY
CAN PREVENT -- I JUST THINK HE
WANTS TO BE AT THE BEACH.
I GOT ELECTED BY SITTING AT
HOME, WHY CAN'T I -- SENDING ME
ON TRIPS, I'LL GIVE YOU TRIPS!
>> Greg: HE WANTS TO DO IS
ZOOM PRESIDENCY AND WHO
WOULDN'T?
WOULDN'T THAT BE GREAT